Where are we looking?
Everywhere. One over here.
Ready? One, Two...
Hey, what's up?
This is Vashtie
and I'm directing
the very special She Got Game
It's my first time working with an all-female crew
and it's been amazing
I have to say
being able to, like, come together with all
these different women from so many different areas
and sort of make this amazing project come to life
Um, we're about to go to location
and shoot a very lovely scene with Jewell Loyd
This is like me, normally
When I'm on the court
I'm totally different
For sure!
I kind of flip the script a little
Are we recording?
I always know where the camera's at
Alexis Morgan, reporter
We're here at the She Got Game set
We're all getting ready
[singing] I believe I can fly
One more time!
Faith Mothershed! She Got Game
My heart went BOOM BOOM BOOM!
And now the Jewell is going to be my
New- I'm gonna fan-girl her!
and I'm very excited to be included in this
Entire, whole, She Got Game thing
Now she shoots, she scores!